here's another interesting word prom
that was sent by cortaggio a woman
cycles to work alongside a railroad
track at six kilometers per hour that's
an interesting piece of data six
kilometers per hour
every day she arrives at a crossing the
same time that a train does okay
one day she was 50 minutes late
and was overtaken by the train
six kilometers from the crossing and how
many minutes will the train reach the
crossing so let's see if we can
draw a diagram here that can somewhat
describe what's going on this problem so
what's on a normal day on a normal day
she leaves from home
she leaves from home and she goes and
she travels alongside a railroad track
not too different than my own commute on
my own bicycle
actually
i actually do travel along a bike path
that's right along a railroad track
anyway
she leaves here let's say she leaves
here time is equal to zero time is equal
to zero and right at this point right
here maybe that's where the railroad
crossing is right there the train passes
her up and she's traveling at six
kilometers per hour
six kilometers per hour
six kilometers per hour
and what else does it tell us it doesn't
tell us how long it takes her or
or how far she travels so let's just
write let's just say so let's say she
arrives here at t is equal to
a hours
t is equal to a we'll do time in hours
since we're in kilometers per hour so
this this
path takes her eight hours to travel so
it takes her a hours
if we care about the time a
hours
now on this next day she's 50 minutes
late
so in this day she has to travel the
same distance in hot in in well in both
distance and time
but this is this day
she leaves not at t equals zero she
leaves 50 minutes late and since we're
dealing with hours let's write 50
minutes in hours so she leaves that if
this was time equals zero that's when
she normally leaves she's now leaving it
time is equal to 50 minutes or time is
equal to five six hours right 50 minutes
is just 50 over 60
hours or 5 6 hours so time is equal to 5
over six hours this time is equal to
zero hours
and let's see it says
that she was overtaken overtaken by the
train six kilometers from the crossing
so she was overtaken by the train i know
some place over here
and this distance
right here this is where the crossing is
that's that crossing this is six
kilometers
six kilometers
and how many minutes what will the train
reach the costing so if we can figure
out some way of expressing this time
if we can figure out what this time is
we know that the train reaches the
crossing at t is equal to a so if we
know this time we could just find the
distance the difference between these
two times and we would have solved the
problem so let's see if we can figure
out this time
so we know that it normally takes her a
hours to travel this whole distance it
doesn't matter when she leaves it takes
her a hours so in this case it should
also take her a hours
and how long does she have to go when
the when the train passes her up on this
day that she was late how long will it
take her to go this distance right there
well she's traveling at six kilometers
per hour she has to go six kilometers so
in time this is going to take her one
hour
to get you know the train will have long
past her but to get back to the crossing
she's going to have to travel for
another hour so if her whole tr if her
whole
route takes her a hours if this whole
length and time is a hours
then this distance right here is going
to have to take her what she has an hour
left her whole trip is going to be a
hours so this is going to be a minus 1
hours let me scroll down a little bit
this is going to take her a minus 1
hours
so on the day she was late it took her a
minus 1 hours to get passed by the train
what time are we talking about right
here
what time is this this is t is equal to
well we started at five sixths
t is equal to five six that's where we
started plus the amount of hours she
traveled plus a minus one
so there we i think we now have all the
information we need to solve this
problem on the day she's late the train
passes her at time is equal to five six
plus a minus one hours where a is the
amount of time it normally takes her to
travel her entire route to the crossing
we know that the train passes this point
at t is equal to a so if we want to know
how many minutes does it take the train
to go from this point to this point we
just have to subtract the two times
so the the
the minutes it takes well the hours
because we're dealing in hours i
remember i did i said 50 minutes was 5 6
of an hour so the minutes it takes is a
that a
minus
this
minus 5 6
plus
a
minus 1 right that's just the difference
in time for the train in hours so this
is a
minus 5 6
minus a
plus 1. luckily the a's cancel out
a's a minus a and you're left with 1
minus 5 6 hours which is just equal to 1
6 hours
there are 60 minutes in an hour so 1 6
of that is 10 minutes
so it takes the train 10 minutes to get
to the crossing from the point that it
passed her another neat problem and i
thank cortaggio for that and then you
can actually use this information if you
want to figure out how train how fast
the train is going or you could even
think of other types of kind of
derivative problems off of this one
anyway another good problem